j'accueille jean patrick capdevielle
[Musique]
il est peintre il ay les cinéastes à ses
heures il vit à ibiza et sa chanson tu
es dans le désert qui est un rock
français vous l'entendez beaucoup sur
les antennes il a une vraie personnalité
[Musique]
u2
jacques effet mirage le disent de faire
de
la paix les neiges me suis tu avances
du syndicat des marchands de certitudes
amman une offre aux gens m'ont à titi
c'est pas très populaire le goût de la
solitude
non
c'est dans les airs
depuis trop longtemps
demanda quizas
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
jean patrick capdevielle à paris le
chanteur n'a pas changé karoutchi
anarchiste libertaire et c'est comme ça
que constituer mon cerveau passé comme
ça q
et transversal dans tous les enfants et
jean-patrick analysons toute lucidité
les raisons de sa traversée du désert
j'ai un sens très très fort de ce qui
est populaire c'est à dire que c'est
généralement ce que je déteste quand je
d'état sa main sur mon premier album
j'ai toujours la chanson que je
détestais c'est toujours la chanson que
la maison de 10 je vous laisse je
voulais sortir en single et c'est là
qu'il braquait marché et lorsque j'ai
lorsque j'ai eu à suffisamment
d'autorité pour dire non à cette chanson
ne sortira pas en single et ben là ça a
beaucoup moins bien marché l'auteur
compositeur interprète n'a pas pour
autant renoncé à la musique
on le retrouve dans le 9e arrondissement
de paris il vient de créer une web radio
petites structures
un bureau et quelques ordinateurs ma
radio à - d'abord que je vous dise un
truc ma radio à moi n'est pas une radio
c'est un outil à fabriquer des radios et
ça n'est pas la radio de jean patrick
capdevielle d'accord c'est clair la
radio à moi c'est la radio des gens qui
la font ça je trouve ça c'est exactement
ça
[Musique]
ibiza mme new york londres jean patrick
a toujours voyagé mais c'est dans paris
sa ville natale qu'il semble perdu et
c'est unique à la fois qui m'émerveille
toujours autant et je connais toujours
aussi mal première chose que je fais
c'est d'aller essayer de retrouver un
périphérique
où que je sois il faut traverser à
traverser paris / d'alter il ya un
endroit qui est clair pour moi c'est la
banlieue à la banlieue
dès que je traverse je suis l'autre côté
du périphérique
dès que j'ai mis deux roues motrices je
suis perdu je suis officiellement perdu
dans les années 60 il a côtoyé les
beatles les stones hendrix aujourd'hui
c'est d'un jeune groupe de rock dont
jean patrick s'occupe
[Musique]
cana d'autres non cotées dans le désert
depuis trop longtemps et
et jean patrick capdevielle ne se fait
pas prier
ouais
vendée
[Applaudissements]
non mais
[Musique]
je me suis tu
c'est dans le désert
oh la la
qui sait
et si j'avais su gérer ça pour risquer
pour ça je t'appelle
je dis pas je dis pas que je chanterai
plus jamais mais
j'ai trop dans vie dans tous les sens en
fait je pense que j'ai jamais été qu'un
fan un fan qui avait la chance de faire
de la musique je pense que j'ai ça
là quand j'ai chanté là
je chante et là ça a été vrai
franchement pas ce que j'avais vu des
tas de gens que j'aime ici
l'olympia à chaque fois que j'essaie
d'entrer dans le moule je me plante je
dois être crédible où je fais mal
peut-être que le seul talent gc d'avoir
de l'audace l'audace et le cran de
dévoiler ce qui le met en colère
aujourd'hui il ya un truc qui est
atterrant pour moi
[Applaudissements]
ça ça c'est vraiment un truc ça
m'angoisse pas mais ça me met en colère
c'est de savoir que j'ai vécu plus de
jours que je vais en vivre
j'ai peut-être 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans je
sais pas mais devant ce pape cesse pas
beaucoup plus soir
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
jean patrick capdevielle
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue dans tu m'en a
parlé
alors vous êtes né le 19 décembre 1945 à
levallois-perret d'une famille
bourgeoise originaire du sud ouest
il faisait quoi vos parents mon père
était ingénieur il travaillait dans une
usine s'appelle hispano suiza qui
s'appelait s'est passé de schiste lilith
l'exerice ville il dirigeait le bureau
d'études
alors fils unique fils unique enfant
gâté c'est un peu trop une enfant
précoce aussi vous avez le bac à 15 ans
15 ans et demi et puis trois ans de
médecine et de droit mais en dilettante
ça vous ça vous branche est assez riche
passé beaucoup plus de temps à la
cinémathèque
oui dans les cinémas de saint michel que
1 et puis j'ai rendu une copie
humoristique à la fin de ma deuxième
année de médecine qui m'a valu de passer
devant le devant le conseil de la de
l'université qui était présidée par le
président du sénat je donne je signe et
landru et je donne rendez vous
l'examinatrice avec c il m'a dit me voir
des comptes va déranger tout ce monde je
dis moi je n'ai rien demandé
alors les salles d'art et d'essai les
concerne les voyages et en fait vous
rêvez peintre à 17 ans vous allez voir
un galeriste qui aiment votre peinture
et il vous dit est ce que tu es prêt à
crever de faim pendant 15 ans et là non
j'ai réfléchi pas mal et est entre temps
j'avais un petit garçon qui était né ça
il fallait il fallait nourrir les
petites têtes blondes pour nourrir la
petite tête blonde nous donner
mercenaires avant après ce jeûne chez
daniel filipacchi
je travaille à celui que copains
mademoiselle achetant j'ai travaillé un
peu à lui et puis petit à petit je suis
passé de deux rédacteurs et photographes
ouais ça a été une chose un petit peu de
naturel comme ça et puis
puis directeur artistique voilà tout est
bon pour financer des week-ends à
londres des trois mois à new york des
traversées des usa en bus volkswagen
voilà quoi c'est une bonne époque mais
c'était c'était une époque où j'allais
jallet respirer à londres parce que
comme je l'avais j'avais les cheveux
jusque là une et que je me faisais
insulter à tous les coins de rue à paris
ce qu'on me dit que je devais que
l'avion se poser à londres voilà mais
c'est au bistrot de la rue françois 1er
à côté de d'europe 1 que vous rencontrez
eric clapton et là vous commencez par
admirer vos vestes respectives
oui effectivement quand je suis arrivé
il avait la célèbre veste militaire de
des débuts de crime assez sobre
finalement et moi j'avais une veste
encore drogue en jour
finn milleret et je lui dis jolie veste
dit la tienne aussi on échange
évidemment il est plus beaucoup plus
petit que moi à se dire que ça va
arriver là et devient flotter dans la
vienne crime est reparti le lendemain et
puis lui il est resté quelques jours je
les amener un petit peu partout et
je pense que deux brigades après je suis
allé à londres et puis on finissait par
me prendre comme j'accompagnais les
inconvénients des tournées ils pensent
que cris mais ils étaient quatre ans que
j'étais habillé comme j'avais même
jusque là vous découvrez le swinging
london ainsi une époque absolument
extraordinaire le speakeasy 1 vous
rencontrez wagner sur le blaze is to
savoir où et quand on était accompagné
de clapton à cette époque là où quand on
accompagne et clapton on pouvait se
retrouver à une table où il y avait de
rolling stones tour 3 beatles loin
intériste hendrix vendredi et daltrey
enfin section grande époque il là vous
avez vos premières velléités de faire de
la musique
vous allez voir jacques bolson le
producteur de dutronc avec une cassette
vous avez mis votre voix sur une chanson
des rolling stones et par dessus la voix
de mick jagger
c'est un duo assez étonnant en même
temps il y avait un garçon là qui
s'appelait jacques dutronc j'ai appris
par la suite il y avait un rôle sonne et
il y avait landesman dans la même lettre
les trois jacques et ce garçon n'avait
pas encore sorti son disque un n'diaye
et tu veux bien écouter ça alors il ya
en plus sa bande c'est un peu
l'atmosphère était un peu tendu parce
que la bande s'est un peu emmêlé etc il
me fait écouter jeudi se ressemblent
antoine en moins bien et chaque fois que
ces petites filles les campus et
vulgaire à l'intérieur de deux vols qui
étaient entre son producteur et le
producteur d'antoine et j'ai refais une
once man qui me dit alors moi je dis non
je restais dans le journal pour la santé
et bien c'est plus sûr après cette
période de mercenaires de la presse vous
décidé de créer un mensuel pour les
filles
c'était l'époque où il y avait pas mal
de jeunes éditeurs ambitieux qui voulait
s'attaquer à l' empire filipacchi sur
les jeunes
donc comme j'avais cette expérience-là
qui en plus j'avais été directeur
artistique je publie si j'avais bon je
trouvais un peu me maîtriser la création
d'un magazine comme ça ils m'ont
j'ai été approché par plusieurs il y en
a entre particuliers qui est devenu
chanteur par la suite sous le nom de
laroche valmont qui s'appelait jean
cantin gérard et qui m'a demandé notre
au point pour lui une formule et j'ai
fait une formule c'est devenu stéphanie
sur moi de la garder pour lui moi j'ai
fait une sorte de stéphanie bis mec à
qui a moins bien marché mais
suffisamment marché pour que sardou s'y
intéresse il m'en achète l'île à faire
voilà est donc là vous vous prenez une
année sabbatique pour peindre 12 heures
par jour voilà voilà et c'est je fais ça
avec un peu d'excès et j'avais tout fait
une peinture très libre très gestuelle
comme ça et là je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
pris des photos que j'avais prises aux
états unis sans vie sans viser comme ça
au hasard et j'ai décrite avec des
lignes verticales comme si c'était sur
un écran de télévision
donc c'est exactement le contraire de ce
que je faisais un travail très appliqués
sur les gigantesques toiles je me suis
ennuyé mais à mort 1
et au bout de 9 mois je suis non je n'ai
rien dit là il faut vraiment que soit
pas transmis le féru et c'est ça je les
fais sérieusement c'est à dire des
choses - chef et je fais un truc
sérieusement ça marche pas voilà donc ce
que vous allez assez effectué sa malle à
c est qu elle pendant une semaine je me
suis retrouvé comme disent les
bouddhistes sansan son plafond sur la
tester au dessus de la tête et sans
plancher sous les pieds et
et la chose la plus naturelle que j'ai
fait ça a été de prendre une guitare qui
traînait là et sur laquelle eric avait
joué donc voilà j'ai écrit deux trois
chansons je suis allé voir de la seule
personne que je connaissais à l'époque
s'appelait patrick gandolfi qui était un
garçon que j'avais j'avais connu à
l'époque où je travaillais actuelle et
je vais montrer et il m'a dit je te
signe je suis finalement c'est facile il
ya eu solitude réveillère plein de mots
comme ça sans français marche c'était
une sorte de régler ça ça ça a bien
marché
en tout cas ça marche et suffisamment
pour que lorsque la boîte de 10 de
william sheller kim avait signé s'est
arrêtée parce que ketchup musique aux
noceurs s'est arrêté je me suis retrouvé
libre deux contre un et savez ce type
qui passait un à fond sur sur aube sur
elle et ça donc voilà ils sont
intéressés à moi est alors en 1979 vous
sortez chez cbs quand tu es dans le
désert où l'avait écrite comment cette
chanson j'avais une dizaine de chansons
et au dernier moment je me rends compte
j'entendais de temps en temps
monte-carlo radio monte carlo qui avait
une chanson qui ressemble terriblement à
l'encré de tes yeux de cabrel mais je me
dis c'est pas possible il faut que j'en
écrive une autre et tout à toute allure
j'ai écrit une j'ai écrit
musique dans l'avion j'ai écrit les
paroles et je n'aimais pas du tout cette
chanson alors d'abord je voulais pas la
mettre sur le disque les gens qui en
occupant enregistrer mon fils il faut
l'admettre je t'assure a été efficace
une fois qu'elle était sur 10 je voulais
pas le sortir en single moi jouer pas
défendre ça s'appelait quand tu es dans
le désert et on la ressort toujours 35
ans plus tard bah oui c'est un tube
absolument énorme
j'ai fait une erreur terrible c'est à
dire que tous les huit mois je sorte un
album mais j'ai rencontré des gens qui
achetaient le troisième album et qui me
disait mais comment il n'ya pas quand tu
es dans le désert doit mais s'il pense
que j'ai fait le premier et ça c'est un
truc emmerdant corte dans le désert en
fait en l'écoutant il me critique du
giscardisme l'époque je n'étais pas du
tout aperçu il ya un gros clowns
sinistre c'est vraiment barrages y est
un piège de la corde elodie mais je
m'étais jamais rendu compte de ça je
m'en suis aperçu en préparant cette
émission est alors il s'est passé un
truc vraiment est vraiment étrange
c'était je venais d'acheter une ruine
maintenant à maison le vin je venais
d'acheter une ruine et j'étais en train
d'enlever racing pour sauvegarder des
des murs et j'écoute est donc monté
carlo sur 7 sur un petit et pas un truc
comme ça et d'un seul coup j'entends ma
chanson ouais il c'est pas possible
c'était extraordinaire
et c'était vraiment tout au début
c'était la première fois je l'entendais
la radio et là des annonces c'était dans
mon pote avec des paroles comme ça tu
vas pas souvent d'entendre ta chance
j'étais effondrée alors vous était
célèbre immédiatement non ça a été ça a
été trop rapide ça a été trop rapide
parce que le chiffre pas rendu compte
que ce métier était un métier difficile
d'abord parce que j'avais pas fais des
petites boîtes avec des groupes et
c'était 1-0 les mains un petit club
comme ça ce qui fait que ça m'a paru
normal je m'attendais à ce que personne
n'écoute mon 10mai le fait d'eux des
disques de platine et la coke zero 400
milles saint brès est tout aussi normal
voilà et donc je faisais attention à
rien j'avais aucune stratégie de
carrière rien du tout quelles ont été
les réactions de votre entourage confié
eu cet énorme tube mes amis avant fin de
mes amis la plupart des gens de mes
proches a été tu as changé avant même
que j'aie le temps de jeu
quant à ma mère ça a été tu me mens je
les ai lu dans un journal que tu avais
fait ça et je passe à tu me dis que tu
fais bien journal dit que est d'accord
voilà c'est en gros c'était ça mais
c'est pas très agréable finalement je
suis un fils de woodstock et de trucs
comme ça moi je suis un fils de non
seulement du swinging london aussi de
dudu de la mairie qui piquent quoi et
pour moi c'était mes références c'était
jim morrison c'était dylan c'était même
jagger donc savez savez ça oscillé entre
le grand spectacle et la messe et la
cérémonie
je me suis retrouvé passé chez dit luc
centre entre sheila et dalida avec un
tipi deux genres un gars tu deviens et
voilà je ne fais qu un petit que
difficilement policier aucun mépris
sincèrement j'avais aucun mépris ni pour
celle à nu pour dalida
elle faisait leur truc je faisais le
mien je pensais que si celle a été celle
à que c'était la meilleure de toutes les
filles qui voulaient chellah et la lisa
c'est la même chose donc tout allait
bien mais c'est on n'était pas dans la
même heure on veut pas dire la même
chose on ne parlait pas de la même chose
mme et avec les médias ça s'est passé
comment je pensais être attaqué par les
par les médias grand public
ouais et je pensais que les médias un
peu branché à l'aimer
me défendre et c'est qu'il s'est passé
exactement le contraire et avec une
virulence qui m'a qui m'a surpris alors
je vais peut-être j'ai peut-être
réagit un peu violemment pour l'amour ça
a été bien tu as passé veille c'est à
dire qu'il fallait il fallait franchir
les les cours d'hier les et de deux fans
sortie des concerts c'était ça c'était
ça s'était très près sens j'ai connu ça
quand même j'ai connu des défis qui
campaient devant ma maison et ben issa
qui est à 4 km de chemins de terre du
village le plus proche quand même
ouais c'était micky camper devant la
tente et tout mais c'est comme ça c'est
quoi le meilleur moment de toute cette
époque je pense que ça a été quand j'ai
enregistré mon premier 45 tours au
studio ferber avec des copains et qui
est ce qu'on était bourré de champignons
hallucinogènes
d'accord ça a été formidable et le pire
c'est le lendemain matin de 50 ans a
senti le champignon pendant huit jours à
décembre donc alors un succès public
très important mais la critique ne vous
aime pas c'est à dire que deux cônes
manoeuvre vous reproche vous en prend à
springsteen à dylan vous accuse d'être
un pont peur ils font de l'anti
capdevielle primaire quoi
oui je croyais même eu un article dans
libé qui était signée de kolpa kopoul
qu'elysée un danger nouveau menace le
rock français le cap de vialis mhz alors
il dit c'est ce type là n'ira jamais sur
scène alors que mes concerts étaient
annoncées dans nos mines dans le même
but à la fin de la libération et il
accusé il disait et et d'autres vont se
glisser dans la brèche qu'il a créée par
exemple bashung vachon que j'avais 10
ans du métier
il avait il y avait à se glisser dans la
brèche de personnes voilà c c'est dû à
quoi ça vous l'expliquez comment dont
j'avais été journaliste je faisais un
type de musique que ces gens-là aimé et
qui se sont tous fantasmé dans le rôle
que j'avais qui avait été le mien ouais
alors y avait un autre problème quand
même c'est que vous vouliez pas vraiment
être chanteur comme n'est pas transformé
le plaisir de chanter en corvée d'une
certaine façon
non je voulais pas je voulais pas jouer
pas de métier surtout je ne vais pas
devenir un chanteur de métier je ne vous
ai pas voulu être chanteur et après vous
commencez à faire des clips à vous
tourner vers le cinéma
et puis vous vous dites finalement trois
ans pour faire un film c'est quand même
super long oui je serai pas je serai pas
réalisateur
en fait ce qui s'est passé j'ai
expérimenté le truc c'est à dire qu'un
moment où j'ai pu me payer ça je me suis
payé une année sabbatique puis deux et
je suis allé à los angeles ucla étudié
le cinéma à voyager je pouvais le faire
je les fais des gens qui s'achètent des
voitures très puissante moi j'étais ça
et en revenant j'ai fait j'ai fait un
certain nombre de clips dont un qui
était un peu pour que je chante qui
était considérable y avait beaucoup de
monde sur on a tourné deux fois 23
heures de suite le prouve sa femme à un
moment mais disons maintenant si tu fais
un plan de purge de pleurer et je me
suis rendu compte que voilà cg je vivais
des petits films d'une certaine façon
avec 81 100 personnes sur l'industrie un
vrai long je vais pas pouvoir
gpg pas ça en moi vous êtes très bon
parce qu'après vous faites un coup
formidable et mâcha plein vous avez
quand même vendu deux millions et demi
d'albums mais ça c'est autre chose ça
c'est un truc que j'avais depuis
longtemps monsieur mon père écoutait
beaucoup d'opéras ma grand-mère était
premier prix de conservatoire du
conservatoire de piano à bordeaux à 12
ans va c'était un peu dans la famille
écouté beaucoup d'opéras et moi j'ai
toujours aimé l'opéra et mes fils aime
l'opéra aussi ça c'est curieux ça s'est
passé comme ça et j'avais écrit un
certain nombre de champs entre le pop et
l'opéra et dans les maisons de disques
quand je faisais écouter sans se marrer
les gens fiancé il ya eu bocelli que je
le bonze le bon goût de faire un succès
avec ça alors évidemment comme ils ont
beaucoup d'imagination dans les maisons
de disques
ils sont venus voir mises en conférence
va faire un deuxième bocelli bien on va
faire au moins une bonne celle là
et alors voilà j'avais sélectionné une
petite jeune fille il se plaignait rasé
fille aurélie et elle n'a pas compris ce
qui se passait quand elle allait passer
complètement à côté du truc elle disait
monsieur capdevielle je peux pas parce
que parce que j'ai gdg des mariages les
baptêmes voilà vous avez chanté et donc
j'ai cherché et j'ai trouvé une jeune
fille qui s'appelait autrement et que
j'ai appelé ma chaplin oui et puis boum
voilà deux millions et demi c'est pas
mal quoi oui puis alors deux millions et
demi s'est passé assez inaperçu en
france on avoue vendu quand même quatre
cent mille en france on a fait des
scores dans les pays
un probable qu'on a été la plus grosse
vente française de tous les temps en
nouvelle zélande
ah oui on est on a été la plus gore ça
c'est un truc dont je suis fier parce
que c'est le la plus grosse vente
étrangères sur un an en israël plus que
les beatles pink floyd sur un an
quintuple e10 de diamant un truc comme
ça ça lui alors aujourd'hui est ce que
vous êtes nostalgique de l'époque de
kanté dans le désert il ya des choses
qui me manquent mais il ya des choses
la naïveté vous êtes rancunier par
rapport à des gens justement comme
manoeuvre ou comme de caunes manoeuvre
j'ai fait une émission avec lui c'était
la 100e de son émission il m'a dit c'est
la meilleure qu'on ait faite à vue
d'accords ya plus besoin de rancune
quand quelqu'un vous dit ça y de caunes
de caunes j'aie jamais rencontré de
caunes je crois qu'ils lisaient d'été
des textes qu'on écrivait pour lui alors
je peux pas lui en vouloir
et si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil je me
laisserais encore moins emporté par le
milieu le métier que je les fais nous
préserverait beaucoup plus
ouais encore plus mais je crois que je
crois je n'ai pas fait assez alors si
vous avez une épitaphe à mettre sur
votre tombe ça serait quoi
enfin
pas mal elle est bonne celle là au
revoir
j'étais très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vous merci jean patrick
mercier et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux